okay people who are joining this meeting
we are talking about the code assistance
project and what do we have here
great okay so actually one question that
was raised is wait this is there are two
cases here one is the pre one is the
syntactically correct assist in the
semantics of code and the other is
semantically incorrect try and fix the
incorrect
I'm sorry syntactically I meant
syntactically correct versus
syntactically incorrect is that this
section here is about syntactically
incorrect stuff correct yes okay and so
the way this is triggered is on if you
evaluate this then you will get a syntax
error and this is what you will see in
the syntax error is suggestions about
where to add brackets correct correct
and deleting yeah yeah okay now do we
think that this is going to be indicated
at any time when you haven't
specifically done a shift enter
evaluation and seen a syntax error is
there gonna be a way to trigger this in
in a sort of check syntax type mode yeah
I mean so this touches on the other code
assistance
you know just semantic problems not
necessarily wanting to tie it to
shift-enter evaluations because you know
that specifically does create the
impression in the users mind that this
is tied to evaluation which you know is
if anything the worst thing to do
because we could you know we could be
running this before evaluation and just
seemed you know magical and we're fixing
code before you run it and everything
and so you know we've talked about
adding a menu item fine you do the
checking yeah all right
don't think a menu item is gonna cut it
I think what we want to do instead is
there's gonna be some heuristic probably
based on time I would suspect if you
leave a I mean so let's let's talk about
how that might work so for example if
you have a cell see it's hard to know
what the workflow is here yeah I I'm
very worried about the notion of a
time-based Juris I'm actually abandoned
in that temperature I think about it
doesn't make any sense um the question
is you've been typing and I mean
honestly you've been typing and you
think it's correct and um did we get
Noah in this meeting by the way I was
just wondering whether he was it was he
able to join us he's not here now but I
can try to fetch him I was hoping he
would be here um okay
I asked for him okay um okay in any case
so look the one case we know this is
going to happen as if you did a shift
enter and you got this and you had a
syntax error so then the question is um
is there another way to get that to
happen preemptively and there probably
should be in fact look yeah what should
happen is if you do code checking if you
ask it to check this piece of code it
should obviously check this if it's not
syntactically correct it should do these
kinds of things right yeah I guess I
just didn't realize that you were
thinking of them potentially as two
different things yeah I agree that it
should be so there's as soon a semantic
and syntactic checks can just be one
thing right but this so that means that
design-wise this has to align with
whatever we're doing for the squigglies
underneath things when we think that
they might be semantically wrong well
can we do a semantic check if the
syntactic stuff is probably not which
means we have to signal that if you ask
for a semantics check but it's
syntactically wrong we probably need to
make that more clearer yeah but you know
it might be a moot point okay but but
wait a second wait sir can you do it or
can you not do it can you do it for
sub-expressions or not yeah we can it
the purser proceeds with parsing even in
the face of syntax errors I mean
obviously the syntax error itself you
know the expression around that might be
wrong and bad but you know further down
the line you know things might still
work fine and you could still get
information back out okay but but if
there is a possibility that nothing was
done on the semantic checker then I
think we need some notifier that says
the thing wasn't syntactically correct
sure sure okay but let's look at these
designs well III think in general even
when you're you know even though one is
triggered by shift-enter evaluation
having syntactic correctness looks
significantly different from a sorry
syntactic incorrectness looks
significantly different from semantics
and correctness is important okay so so
I don't think the appearance needs to be
specific to you triggered it by hand I'm
just in general and there are other
modes other actions I suppose that could
trigger the checking menu item yes but
also I mean you know possibly cursory
out of the cell you know like there
there are different events that could
signal a fencepost
the to say that you're it's now okay to
do the check I don't know what a full
exploration of those would be okay oh
yeah that's not relevant to what we're
doing here let's look at what we're
doing here which is which is
specifically dealing with the graphic
design of what happens to add a
character so I don't understand why it's
blue to add a character I don't even
understand what what you mean by higher
confidence levels how are you intending
to put in higher confidence levels
they're darkening of the bracket the
visually is meant to be indicated by the
chevron combinations okay all right and
fun there were some percentages in the
original mock-up the prototype from
Timothy okay and and we're also planning
the darkness of the bracket to indicate
the confidence in some way is that
correct the chevrons and the darkness of
the bracket together correct we can yeah
okay what I recommend in terms of the
removal is that we use the pink metaphor
since we've already got a pinking
metaphor for other things why not just
do what you've indicated for hover why
not pink box the bracket do you see what
I'm saying yes I would say why not have
the Chevron's pointing downwards that
mean you should delete it so to speak
Chevron's pointing upwards means you
shouldn't insert it Chevron's pointing
down means you should delete it and
personally I think they should both be
read well probably comments from other
people
yeah I think that the idea of having two
different colors was just distinguish
insertion from deletion but I but I
suppose if one is pointing up and when
it's pointing down when that would kind
of something that would work
Jeremy do ya you'd say if it was
deletion wouldn't the bracket be solid
black already wouldn't go gray with it I
think that's well that's a brenton
question brenton and john question I'm
sorry if if it was deleted then so so
for deletion probably the state we're in
is the black it bracket is black it has
a pink background it has that kind of
pink background pink box background and
it has Chevron's pointing down okay if
that's the case I think that's good
enough right ones gray ones black we
have the down Chevron's I think that's
enough of a difference I think so and
it's got a pink box I'm sorry what ones
grey ones black I'm sorry it's something
I didn't follow there yeah so what
happens is there are two cases you got
to pay attention to no there are two
cases okay
case number one is insertion something
is being added case number two is
deletion right what I'm proposing is on
deletion the bracket stays black because
it was already there you understand what
I'm saying
it has a pink box behind it now it to be
clear it wasn't initially black what do
mean it wasn't initially back and when
you typed it in it wasn't black it was
it was a purple magenta oh sorry I don't
know how to identify identify the color
but the because it was an additional I
see okay then you should leave it
whatever it color it was okay making
sense if it was magenta leave it magenta
okay understood
yes Billy yes sorry
also in the insertion case
and I'm sorry I should have caught this
with Billy in an earlier meeting but in
the insertion case I think when you
mouse over it would be good to have some
kind of highlighting of the thing it's
matching yes yes
okay all right so let's go through again
the visual design here okay so the
visual design is brackets don't brackets
that are to be deleted do not change
color they stay there syntax coloring
color but they get a pink background and
they get a down pointing Chevron with
the number of Chevron's indicating the
confidence that makes sense to people
one one tricky thing here which is maybe
I just have to think about with Timothy
but is if you have multiple closing
square brackets they're identical if he
always identifies the last one then that
last one is probably going to be the one
that will be magenta but if is algorithm
ends up choosing another one that one
would be black I don't know there will
be a preference to to annotate the
magenta one yeah yeah so that's you know
I'll just have to coordinate with
Timothy on that right and on hover
indicating the matching back it would be
highly useful but wait a minute if it's
being deleted there isn't a matching
bakit right so this on Wow assuming of
course the machine learning algorithm is
is you know perfect in that regard yeah
but I think we're not going to be able
to pick up the bracket match sure is no
liz is will just confuse people to
indicate there is a matching bracket
when the my I agree I agree so I think
there's nothing to hover there's nothing
- yeah - okay so then then um okay so
then what I suggest right so on hover I
think it should just go to what I don't
know how deep you want to make the pink
and so on but I
I like the idea of the red border on for
the deletion case right and I mean I I
don't know why on hover it doesn't just
say oh I'll hover it has the tooltip or
not does it not yes it would have a to
type okay so to me tooltip okay in that
tooltip it is unclear what action is
what what what I assume is the case is
that if you hit the tooltip you will
delete that bracket is that not correct
or what you want to do that John I think
that's consistent with other code
assistance stuff if you actually go to
the bracket you delete it but in any
case the tooltip text is at best
confusing because the delete I mean we
understand I mean confidence 99% to most
people
yeah I don't the confidence thing at
best we need to gray that down and make
it smaller okay I think it's sort of
[ __ ] actually I mean um you know
what I don't think we should say it I
mean we can put in something it's like
when search engines in the early days of
search engines they used to tell you you
know confidence of this match being
whatever is whatever and I nobody cared
I'm kind of agreeing with that
I mean I think the only thing that might
be relevant is if there are three
different bracket removals and
somebody's somebody says we'll just make
give me the most probable bracket
removal but I think the way we want to
do that I mean we already have the the
combination you know chevron others
right and I think what we should do is
those Chevron's should be primarily well
we need to understand the quantiles you
know it's like like grading curves or
something we need to understand the
quantiles of where we put these
different Chevron's right because we
might have to equal that requires a
little bit of thought do you get what
I'm saying in other words yeah I mean I
mean for example the you know the naive
notion would be that the lowest one
would be zero to twenty five percent but
but then you would say well why wouldn't
we just throw out anything below 25
percent because it's garbage well or if
there's a look the basic issue is if the
top-ranked deletion is only a twenty six
percent confidence what do you do yeah
right and you know I think so I think we
need to look at the case where so first
question is how many deletions are we
likely to be given and this is a
question for Timothy I don't know the
answer to that if if we think so for
example one thing we could do is decide
we're not going to support more than
four possible deletions we're just gonna
mean I would suggest that it should
probably be less you know I'm my own
thing he knows no more than three and
maybe only two okay fine
assuming assuming it and I don't know if
Timothy can figure this out but I am
assuming here that we're talking about
two possibilities to solve the same
bracket matching problem there could of
course be multiple bracket matching
problems and indeed indeed indeed so
okay so then
let's assume there are no more than
three and that the Chevron's represent
for now his honest confidence in
quantiles in in quartiles basically you
see what I'm saying I don't know that
that's going to work but let's try that
so in other words we rank the top three
we take the top three um if there is a
dramatically lower probability for and
again I think Etienne is a ten here
maybe he can speak to what we should do
for this if there's a dramatically if
there are two at eighty percent and one
at five percent I think we just dropped
the one at five percent agreed and the
case of you know if you have eighty
percent and one with 79 percent giving
them different Chevron's well I mean if
they're both really that high they might
not refer to the same bracket matching
yes yeah all right so look we got to do
some experiments we got to put in some
obvious heuristics here you know reject
things that are dramatically lower you
know but but you know just just to throw
something out there I would I would
suggest as a possibility that it might
be you know if there's only three then
it might be forty to sixty 60 to 80 and
80 to 100 and then anything below forty
you just don't see don't know don't know
because if there's only one but
something along those lines maybe those
numbers completely off but something
along those but if you have just one and
it's twenty percent I think you do want
to see that one rather than seeing
nothing
yeah various comments on the livestream
commenting about bad suggestions
feedback mechanisms yes although
probably not for this because this is
pretty low level yes more so for other
code assistance things I think um okay
let's look about talk about insertion so
we got deletion and so that's downwards
pointing Chevron's okay um pinking and
downwards pointing Chevron's so
insertion why don't we use magenta as
the insertion color because that would
be sort of as that writer is that does
that not make sense I don't think we
want red as the insertion color upward
pointing Chevron's in some color but
probably not red although we do use the
red caret to indicate you know missing
argument I don't know what do people
think well people just remember so if
we're adding a bracket like in the first
example here
I mean ignoring the fact that there were
two square brackets you know calling it
you know looking like it's part but it's
really contour plot if we're inserting a
character there remember there's always
going to be the corresponding mismatched
bracket like at the beginning of you
know just after contour job that's not a
Genta that is going to be colored
magenta so my intuition would be that
inserting should also be magenta to just
draw a you know parent like to draw your
eye towards both of those being matching
you know that you would be in Serena's
and it matches with that other thing
over there that is also the same color
all right magenta as a thing to be doing
means an error if people would be
confused about inserting it if it's
magenta I don't know why are you putting
that arrow though I don't think that's
right it wants to be the Chevron's want
to be underneath is very insertion for
her absolutely yeah yeah like an
insertion caret that's absolutely the
right place here now I mean it's for
magenta goes you're gonna have magenta
in the deletion case too though so
they're not going to be distinct if we
want different colors
when are we going to be magenta in the
deletion case if it's unmatched right
it's it's magenta though the jacket
itself is magenta yeah but I'm saying
the Chevron's should be red in the case
should be downward-pointing in red
probably in the case where in the
deletion case and should be
upward-pointing in magenta in the
insertion case it just it's like gray
bracket with up magenta versus what
magenta bracket with red down it just
some LLC make a different suggestion
yeah um I mean what we'll see is a
magenta you know matching bracket here
and then let's see and I don't think I
don't know why this is magenta I mean it
shouldn't be shouldn't it be black
because it's going to be it is going to
be the thing that makes it black you see
what I'm saying well the problem with
black is spotty knits well but it's got
a bit great big Chevron underneath it
well what color is Sarah Chevron
I'm not sure do you think gray is a
better color to spot no I think any gray
level is gonna be problematic but
remember we're not sure it's correct so
we don't want to color it look I think
we should try coloring it gray and it
wouldn't be a problem if the bracket
itself were black or gray but it needs
some color around it really calling
attention to it I know but it's gonna
have the Chevron underneath I think it's
gonna be pretty obvious by it well in it
spends on how much wall of text you're
looking at um let's try it let's try it
let's put the Chevron and what color
should we try the Chevron someone from
the live stream is saying I'm magenta
and pink maybe - yeah yeah yeah I know I
know I know that's a separate issue well
let's get a design done and then let's
worry about either it or you know high
contrast versions of it that are
relevant for for people with reduced
color vision and so on that's a
second-order issue here let's get
something that works first um okay so
okay so what color should we try by
default what color should we start off
with does it make sense to start with
magenta all that look like an error we
could try your blue I suppose anybody
object to trying blue I mean we're gonna
have to determine what this look you
know what this seems like once we have
it so anybody object to trying blue
color for a magenta I don't know nobody
will know it it's yellow green green I
think seems wrong because we use it for
local variables and all kinds of things
like so so one of the things that I'm
thinking about is is what the hover
effect would look like and you know I
mean I think we want some splash of
color to use for the hover effect
because we want to show the thing you're
matching against so if like you know the
blue Chevron's turn into a blue hover
effect do does that also mean a blue
hover effect on the matching bracket now
what about greening how does this relate
to greening print essential Green in
case well so greening you know what's
done right now is all about the text
carat placements if you don't actually
have your selection there it doesn't
green we don't do any hovers on green
now I'm not saying we can't but snot
metaphor the greening metaphor now that
I think about it does seem relevant to
this doesn't it maybe
because it's indicating matching well
matching specifically on one thing of
interests you mean the head I mean this
could match this this could green up my
I mean it's not so I mean we green
potentially two things one is one as a
head and the other is just the matching
delimiter which you know in the case of
a non square bracket would be you know
not I mean it could be like curly brace
or Association or something like that
no I understand that but in the case
where there is a head we might as well
indicate the head in the and the
matching over no it would call more
attention to it just by virtue of you
know I'm taking more space right which
is a good thing don't you agree yeah so
I mean I'm thinking something related to
the greens maybe the hover maybe the
thing I mean I don't like the idea of
using green for the Chevron's because I
think that that suggests that it's
definitively correct which it might not
be
boy 5% confidence
who knows who knows we need experience
with it to know what what the heck's the
story is it shouldn't be green anyway I
don't know
we could try this blue and then we could
try going to green for the hover effect
I'm not sure
Jeremy any thoughts I Green could work
I think greens okay the green red is
interesting I don't know no but we
cannot use the green for the Chevron's
that will not be sensible I don't think
well I think you want to match your
Chevron's with whatever the left-hand
side you know bracket match or you know
function head you want those two to
match up to create a pair all right well
maybe we can try some version of green
for this maybe a dark green I'm not sure
I think the blue is not bad but I like
this idea of contrasting colors between
addition and deletion and insertion all
right well let's try the blue then but
but then the problem is then that means
we're going to have yet another color
not green be the highlight here which
seems wrong to me see what I'm saying
all right you guys have got to try this
try making some mock-ups of it I think
it's gonna that the hover color should
be green but I don't think this should
be green maybe we can get away with
having that be dark green and having the
hover be some kind of light low opacity
green as it is in the greening stuff
we're making sense mm-hmm there will be
actually my best guess is a very dark
green for this Billy you understand what
I'm saying
yes okay okay with respect to these
things here this is the wrong part of
speech I mean this is the wrong what is
it saying it says this is probably how
in the in the other code assistant stuff
what how do we describe an action that
should be taken don't really have
actions like this or do you men not that
I can think of
unless you're referring to Britain's
other stuff I'm talking about Brenton's
of Oh a sorry then I originally the text
you know it was saying did you mean
something you know and people are
familiar with that kind of language
instead of you know editors okay you do
that
you know replace obviously that implies
you know replacing whatever you have
with what it's asking you if you meant
okay the question okay so we could do
that here
if the button meant um if it means
delete
you
then we could just have the button say
delete back it or something
delete and not say that we thought
something was wrong but then that button
has to actually be one that you can
Mouse into and do the deletion and I
don't know what happens then on on
mobile well I was gonna say that I've
been evolving with more feedback from
the tip for the text I've been evolving
the messages from saying you know did
you mean this or that to being more you
know direct I suppose as a way of saying
it and so with these I mean obviously I
don't want to say you know extra bracket
question mark or extra bracket period
but making some kind of statement
well the question is does it take an
action how do you take an action to
delete the bracket can you do it by
mousing into this thing it would be nice
if you could because then you don't have
to be clicking with the cursor and do a
bunch of actions to remove the bracket
if you can see plainly this is the wrong
bracket why not just Mouse into this is
this button and delete it
sure yeah yeah okay so I would say that
it should just say delete
sure I mean if if we even want the text
it might be I want the text otherwise
put it unclear what's gonna happen
I mean strike throughs and I mean I
don't know no I'm kind of graphical
language oh yeah yeah I mean fact we can
definitely include it obviously we just
want a button when you hover over the
thing there's a button that allows you
to take the action of deleting it okay
that's what I think we should do and I
don't know what the button should look
like and how it should make it clear
that it's an action button well I well I
think then in that case it'll be more
uniform with what currently is being
proposed for the winter messages fine
okay all right very quickly let's try
and take a look at the the other whoops
what was that other thing there
so I just had a thought about the whole
tooltip versus button thing so why don't
we just have it in mouse over just
expand the Chevron out into kind of a
fully-fledged but no text you know it's
basically what we're proposing yeah yes
yeah or some kind of notify like thing
that's like a you know what are they
called you know a cartoon character
saying thing what the heck is that
called the thing with the little speech
bubble yeah yeah yeah but the point
being is the Chevron is always a button
but when you mouse over it it expands
into a larger button I see what you're
saying I see that the Chevron that you
could just click the Chevron if you
wanted to yeah yeah that's a nice idea
that's a nice idea especially since it
has the downward pointing thing so
somebody has to figure out the touch
analog of this stuff um by the way so
Carl on the live stream was asking about
using things like GPT to as that is
exactly what the hell what this is doing
this is a machine learning story that's
dealing with us bracket matching um
Ethan is asking for Auto formatting
stuff and I'd like to know from Brenton
what's the state of your error versus
uneri line break yeah actively being
worked on so yeah we're saying before
yeah the live stream started so that is
I could have even mentioned that that's
one other area thing big that's an
extremely important area how is it going
yeah good there are some foundational
papers with code formatting that I've
read through and I'm you know going
through you know the the mistakes that
people have made in the past you know
and in doing all of this and you know
not wanting to bring in gigantic
constraint engines or anything like that
but trying my current philosophy right
now is to be trying to retain as much of
the current formatting as possible be so
basically
formatters work by first throwing away
all the white space and then starting
from scratch I'm not sure that's the
right thing to do I don't think I'm
saying that's what you know other people
do I don't think it's the right thing to
do yeah so it is requiring but it's good
because my parser it works just fine
retaining all the whites okay I would
love to have a meeting about this before
you spend a huge amount of time
inventing all these heuristics because I
think we can probably help with this
then maybe within the next week or so we
can try and meet about that yeah Brian
on the live stream is pointing out that
if the tooltip causes an action then
undo should revert it sure yeah I mean
that will come for free okay okay so
this is how a squiggly I wish there
wasn't a dot there for the little bit
extended squiggly that the eye is drawn
too much that dot but in any case um
okay hover over code okay
hover into the code assistance area
this is nice except I don't believe in I
think Roman numerals don't make it why
do you want to put those Roman numerals
there they came up in conversation but I
think I could remove them I yeah it was
it was part of the what does dismiss
mean and then there was going to be some
extra dismissal options and then those
got removed from the mock-up and just
replaced it with the question of what
does this miss mean I agree that it
needs something to make sure that these
are well I don't know I mean you have a
raise of buttons I mean usually I see
the reason that this looks odd is
because usually that will be a menu of
some kind not that's not even true
John what what what is confusing about
this I mean two separate buttons you're
used to having two buttons in you eyes
that are horizontally aligned you're
less used to having two buttons
vertically aligned and it's more common
to have a menu without without a gutter
between those two things
and of course we could have an axe to
dismiss but it's well no but those are
typically on the right which would be a
pain in the butt in this case I know
this myth here means clear right as
opposed to just closed window and that
the X would be in closed window I think
yes that's correct and we might want an
X as well over on the right just for
convenience but well and just clicking
away should also be closing the little
pop-up
well the is this on hover is this on
click if it's on hover then you don't
even need to click away this is on click
isn't it oh no this is on hover into the
code assistance area so even so on hover
over Linux the little guy pops out I'm
not sure this is going to work because
think some things will be zero cross
section so to speak in other words there
won't necessarily be what do we do when
the squiggly indicating something which
is of zero size that is a good question
so one is I think in that case we'll
just have something which is a some kind
of squiggle notifier go ahead what are
you gonna say why don't I do an example
of that for other for people is implicit
times when you didn't intend it between
symbols or between lines where you know
technically the thing doesn't even exist
and so what are you you know what
where's the squiggly line so we're going
to need to have something which is a
squiggle box so to speak um
what is this case here this is when
there are multiple issues associated
with that thing don't we don't we have
multiple layers of squiggly nasai mean I
don't think this will be very common the
multi case okay I think here this should
just look like a menu I think we should
just forget the gutter forget the
numbers just make it look like a menu
okay so it seems to me and correct me if
I'm wrong Brenton but it seems to me
that the multi the more likely scenario
for the multi case is where the two
errors have different scopes that's what
I think too like when they having two
errors with the same severity same scope
is even more rare and even contrived I
would say fine so but that then also
raises the issue of I mean if for
example if you have one error which
covered the entire switch statement and
another error which covered just
whispering in the switch statement how
would that be which even see that
visually yeah it'll look like a rainbow
of squiggly lines like a spectrum um why
is there a spectrum they're all red well
if the if the whole switch statement
might be something less severe and a
single what is the severity level but
the severity level is being indicated
with what with the greyness of the
squiggly or the color okay but I think
it should go from red to grey or okay
whatever we want to call that red to
pink probably I don't know you we need
that Billy we need some kind of orange
and green and blue but yeah no way it's
green yeah no way it's blue I mean
whether it goes to a thing whether
chevre whether where the hatchings I
think it's probably going to look
ridiculous to have the hatchings be
alternating in
certain you know Morse code or something
but if it is simply going from red to
pink then that makes the problem of
having a more severe problem nested
within a less severe problem you know
that much less visually distinctive no
no no because I think it's going to be
multiple layers of squigglies I don't
think and I don't know what can happen I
mean I assume that the squiggle will
just have to be further down if it had
overlaps other coded overlaps other code
that makes sense John do what what would
you do John what what what well so one
thing we could do and this might look
like crap so it but whoever asked me
about design is we could have the
squigglies by default have a certain
level of opacity and then any place
where they're double painted you know
they'll get brighter I don't know if
that will work
design folk well and it also it's not
clear the hatchings will line up because
those hatchings are determined by the I
mean well we can I mean we can six
that's okay but design for what do you
think about the idea of squigglies of
higher and higher opacity Jeremy Billy
I'm thinking I'm not sure how that's
gonna look so it'll be a stacked sum
could it go either way I mean as far as
squigglies might start out light and go
dark or start dark and go light
depending on this is something in in the
middle of okay you've got a severity a
low severity error low severity
suggestion which has a lightly you know
lightly opaque squiggly and somewhere in
the middle of that or even over lapping
its end is a high severity one or even
over lapping its end is another low
severity one soon it's all completely
possible
unfortunately that they overlap at the
end is it's not gonna work because the
low because that will mean that the
place where it happens to overlap will
go darker and it does hold on though
doesn't that mean that it should be
that's a very problematic area of code
oh come now I know but it's but it's
just gonna look confusing three
different errors and in fact there are
only two but they're overlapping so the
only way to avoid that which again is a
big mess is to stack the squigglies but
if we stack the squigglies who stacks on
top
you see what I'm saying which suggests
that we shouldn't try and stack the
squigglies
I mean I wonder whether we have a chance
to have them weather with decent
probability
they will not align so that they will so
that so their cross hatchings so you'll
be able to visually see them because one
of them will be a different crosshatch
you know in other words the I will pick
up the fact that it's periodic and it
will continue into the other area I
don't know we'd have to try that I think
that might work did you understand what
I'm saying just I threw something in the
chat just to visualize the idea of you
know something getting darker zero
opacity don't trust my choice of color
here but I mean the big problem here is
that the single level is kind of lights
you know well I I think I'm okay okay
here's what I suggest okay I have a
crazy idea that the periodicity of
across hatchings will allow the eye to
see which cross hatchings are which with
which other ones do you understand my
idea or are you talking about frequency
no I'm talking about phase okay do you
understand my idea what I'm saying is if
you've got two superimposed squigglies
and they have and you assume that their
phase it started and you don't want to
start with that dot you want to start
the squiggly always at the same point
the left-hand end is always an up-and-up
squiggle so to speak see what I'm saying
I have a crazy idea would hey sorry when
you were talking about phase I thought
the whole idea was you would start in a
different points for a nested one no I'm
sure I'm saying I'm saying you use the
following heuristic okay the left-hand
end of the squiggly always starts on an
up squiggle there's no dot right you
understand it it starts on a complete
yeah I know what you call those things
sure sure do you call those things
design [ __ ] is there a name for those
things strokes where line
okay well you start on a you have a
whole stroke there okay yes okay now we
are using the heuristic belief that most
of the time the point at which another
squiggly will start will not be an
integer number of stroke widths away
from the part where the previous one
started and I'm making the speculation
which may be incorrect that the eye will
see when you superimpose those two
things that you will see them as each
one as integrated so to speak
did you see what I'm saying so in other
words I see what you're saying I mean on
the one I don't like to on the one hand
I think it will be easy to call out on
the other hand I don't think it will
look particularly pretty I think it will
look like a mess but that may be okay
clean up your code then write the if
anything just to make it more
aesthetically pleasing
so just asking if there was any
consideration of higher frequency
Quigley's oh I see changing the
frequency of the squiggles well that's
another way that you could get this look
we we have to try this thing of
overlapping ones it maybe end up with
more patterns in your school you what
you will even even you'll end up with
miry patterns when the two things oh I
see when they're different frequencies
yes yeah yeah otherwise you'll just end
up with the UM just comb effect and I I
have I can't remember whether the
optical illusion with combs causes you
not to be able to see them or to be able
to see them and that's clearly that the
deciding factor in whether this makes
any sense so the other question is
what's that go ahead I was gonna say
could instead of using slashes or
squigglies could you just use different
shapes like dots
well but how would you pick for the
different things I mean if I mean okay
this reminds me deeply of the issue of
pronouns and languages when you say you
know languages that have multiple
genders for for nouns for example you
say you you have a few extra pronouns as
opposed to saying you know you know
there it's whatever
but you don't really know what it refers
to but nevertheless languages still
manage to work so one possibility here I
mean we could use the heuristic fact
that different severity areas might have
whatever we do is going to be heuristic
if we have multiple things of the same
server so your suggestion NOAA is to use
to have a repertoire of different kinds
of indicators relevant to different
severity levels somehow those have to be
they have to be in a grammar that fits
together but I agree that you could have
something which goes from essentially
dots to essentially these strokes sort
of like the density between the
differences I think where you guys are
sort of talking about I was sort of
originally trying to think of it like
you know if you could put like a three
line cellular automata underneath the
word the more dense the pattern is the
more you know intense the yeah yeah
right I mean the basic question is we
need a collection of these things that
so the idea of having the form of the
squiggly be slightly different for
different severa T's is a way of
essentially adding more pronouns in
effect I mean it's it's gonna be
heuristic it's not always gonna work the
things might collide but and in reality
we only need to really like to two
things overlapping is ninety-nine point
whatever percent of all cases so like we
don't need to go crit two ways but
considering two at least but by the way
I noticed about more like that then we
might have to like rethink why we're
thinking about more but
really in reality and practice at most
I've only ever seen - oh well we'll find
that I suspect as we build this out
we'll get more than that but including
some I think we'll get some the low
priority that's the point I think we'll
get we don't want to feel oh my gosh we
can't add a low priority suggestion
because it will mess everything up by
the way another option they consider
since we have you know these angular
lines here is we can rotate the angles
yep it becomes a cream you know - down
they become crosses three down could you
know become you know most of an asterisk
that kind of thing but wait a minute
wait a minute we don't want the case of
two overlapping things right we don't
want something that looks like three
cases what we could do I suppose it's a
little bit weird is a random rotation of
the lines for each error because if we
did that then when then I claim maybe
that visually you will be able to see
the overlaps correctly see what I'm
saying okay I'm not sure what random
gets you that what I just said didn't
doesn't okay because the whole point is
when you have an overlap right we have
two things that overlap what you want to
do is you want to get it so that the the
eye can distinguish what thing is just
an overlap versus what thing is is yet a
third piece so I'm saying yes so the
overlap essentially you know looks like
a second reverse barber pole overlaid on
the original barber pole but how do you
know which the point is that because you
don't know which one is going to be
where you have to pick random you can't
pick some organized sequence I mean I
suppose you could pick it depending on
the starting point but somebody is
suggesting on the live stream order them
the squiggles by their each one by
length but their own line that won't
work it's a partially ordered set it
isn't doesn't have it because you can
have a so so so you open up the case
where you have a series of partially
overlapping exactly right sure if that's
even possible
well I think I'm sure it's possible I
mean well okay your your statement is
that my I was thinking more about
squiggles be nested rather than
partially I understand I understand
implicit times all things are possible
okay so in other words the expression
tree is not simply a linearization of
the expression tree which would have a
nested structure yeah I bet it isn't I
bet there okay I mean even implicit x
has a precedence all right so this
requires more thought and but I think we
can go ahead and implement you know some
version of what you have here just to
see what it looks like Ally on our live
stream is saying he hopes isn't gonna be
forced to use code assistance how a goal
our goal is to make it like syntax
coloring we're very very very few people
switch it off if any because it just
works nicely I just have more questions
about why he wouldn't want to use it now
well the I mean certainly legitimate
concern is that you don't want it to be
slow you don't want to be slow you don't
want to get away that's why we care
about triggering it yeah you don't want
it stealing keystrokes you don't want it
stealing mouse clicks I mean these are
all I know so it will be triggered and
we still have to decide this it will
certainly be triggered on shift-enter
and it will be triggered hopefully by
something in the right in the in the
menu bar on the right something like
this right well that presupposes that
already exists in that cell bracket
though after I understand but what what
caused it to bother to look at the code
is the question yeah I mean some menu
item is the other I know and then a
second question is with what resources
did it look at the code yeah well I
think we know we need to have another
kernel to look at this yeah and I think
it should happen asynchronously and if
it sees something should put up that red
dot on the right hand side and then you
can look at it and there should also be
a way to pre-emptive I think it's what
we decided last
there should also be a way to
preemptively ask it to look at it well
that's what yeah I mean what would that
mechanism be I told you it's something
in the in the in the gear menu on the
right or a menu item yeah but where did
the gear menu come from or it like to
begin with though because you know as
part of the cell okay on the cloud the
gear menu is already part of the cell
bracket we're going to add that in the
in the desktop okay okay okay
all right I have to go to a different
meeting people are following the live
stream rush can I have another live
stream coming up right in just a few
minutes um thanks all see y'all soon